ah
[Música]
economía estaba viviendo una semana de
muchas protestas sociales hoy miércoles
21 de octubre se convocó de nuevo un
paro nacional por parte de los
sindicatos de las centrales obreras y de
los estudiantes
el motivo de este paro es de defender la
vida adelante un aumento de los
asesinatos y masacres en todo el país
también defender la democracia según los
sindicatos y en particular el derecho a
la protesta y por fin quieren buscan
desde varios meses de negociar un pliego
de emergencia con medidas económicas y
sociales con el gobierno colombiano algo
que no han logrado todavía y que esperan
poder lograr hoy con esta marcha la
semana había pesado también con una
minga indígena una marcha indígena que
llegó hasta a la capital bogotá para un
debate con el presidente iván duque algo
que no ocurrió
el presidente duque no salió a negociar
a dialogar con los indígenas entonces
ellos siguen en las calles de bogotá
hasta hoy apoyan este paro nacional
y van a devolver para sus territorios al
sur occidente del país
[Música]
en costa rica la población especialmente
sindicatos del sector público y grupos
de oposición protestan en las calles
hace casi un mes desde entonces se han
realizado manifestaciones y bloqueos en
carreteras el detonante fue el plan del
presidente carlos alvarado para resolver
la crisis económica que incluía el
incremento de los impuestos la
ciudadanía se opone a pagar más tributos
para subsanar el déficit fiscal que el
país arrastraba previo a la pandemia y
que ahora se proyecta será cerca del 10%
del producto interno bruto el
presidente- alvarado retiró su propuesta
pero las protestas continuaron y se
tornaron violentas hoy día los bloqueos
en las calles han cesado el ejecutivo
junto a la asamblea legislativa llamaron
a un diálogo que varios actores no han
atendido como el sector privado que
prefirió sentarse a negociar con
dirigentes del movimiento rescate
nacional a quienes la justicia les
investiga por obstrucción de la vía
pública entorpecimiento de servicios
públicos e instigación pública los
líderes de los bloqueos dijeron que
ahora realizarán otro tipo de
manifestaciones el gobierno mientras
tanto lleva a cabo mesas de diálogo
territoriales con las
tales
[Música]
en situaciones normales en argentina no
pasa casi un día sin que haya una
protesta callejera por reclamos sociales
o salariales pero con la pandemia de
coin 19 los reclamos sociales se
redujeron en forma significativa también
se contuvieron los reclamos salariales
de todos modos a mediados de octubre se
alcanzó un acuerdo entre sindicatos
empresas y el estado que llevara el
salario mínimo en argentina a 21.600
pesos en marzo de 2021 esto es
equivalente a unos 278 dólares al cambio
oficial lo aprobado representa un
aumento del 28 por ciento respecto del
salario mínimo que había sido
establecido si un año pero el efecto de
la inflación seguramente termina
licuando ese incremento y si bien muchos
trabajadores están enmarcados dentro de
convenios colectivos entre empresas y
sindicatos que garantizan sueldos más
altos el salario mínimo no deja de
marcar un piso y una referencia un piso
muy bajo la canasta básica promedio para
un hogar argentino vale más del doble
que el nuevo salario mínimo
[Música]